meet your new Princess Peach the
official trailer for The Super Mario
Brothers movie is finally here and on
top of revealing the princess's new
voice it's full of fun Mario references
both obvious and obscure
to kick off the second Super Mario
Brothers movie trailer in Grand fashion
we see Mario emerge from a dark tunnel
into a gladiatorial Arena to face his
opponent Donkey Kong the two puts on
their game faces and charged toward one
another as we get a better look at the
massive steel beam structure they're
standing on while it may be odd to see
Mario and DK as adversaries these days
the two gaming icons started out as
opponents and in a similar environment
to boot way back in 1981 Nintendo
released a Donkey Kong arcade game it
has players control a little Mustachio
man who later became Mario as he
attempts to rescue his beloved Pauline
who was being captured by the titular
gorilla to save her Mario mascale level
after level of Steel beams much like the
ones in the trailer more dodging barrels
and defending himself against Kong's
other forms of attack
oh Donkey Kong wow
in 1994 Nintendo brought Donkey Kong
back in a big way with Donkey Kong
Country which actually saw the grandson
of the original Kong the original now
elderly arcade star appeared in Donkey
Kong Country as crankygonk AKA Donkey
Kong senior in the trailer an APU looks
a lot like cranky is watching the battle
clearly happy to see the young gorilla
take Mario down all in all the newest
Super Mario Brothers movie trailer is a
fast-paced blink and you'll miss it
Affair that served as a highlight reel
for the film itself that means that it
doesn't give viewers much time to take
in the animated environments of the
movie's heroes and villains and habit
nevertheless we do get a look at some
noteworthy locations throughout the fans
of the Super Mario franchise are quite
familiar with first and foremost are
good looks of the Mushroom Kingdom and
Bowser's Lair but they're just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to famous
Luke house thanks to a map that several
toes examine we see that areas like
shifting sandland exist in this version
of the Super Mario Universe we also see
the home of some cheap Jeeps who jump
effortlessly over Bridges just as they
do in their video game appearances
[Music]
speaking of homes a trailer also offers
a brief look at Yoshi's Island where
several Yoshis run from an unseen entity
finally there's a notorious Mario Kart
track Rainbow Road wish our heroes
bravely drive on despite the lack of
guard rails the bane of many a gamer's
existence
one of the many selling points of the
new Super Mario Bros movie teaser is the
introduction of Anya Taylor Joy's take
on Princess Peach she's noticeably
absent from the previous trailer so she
gets a lot of time to shine in this one
not only does it appear as though she
won't be kidnapped by Bowser but she
seems to be a strong capable leader
Peach makes no bones about her desire to
take the fight to Bowser if it means
keeping her kingdom safe and in doing so
the trailer reveals that she'll wear a
few different outfits that have
histories rooted in the Super Mario
franchise it should come as no surprise
that for much of the second Super Mario
Brothers movie trailer Princess Peach is
wearing her most recognizable costume a
pink dress Golden Crown and white gloves
however it does change when she picks up
the flame of a fire flower with her
attire taking on a white and red Motif a
mechanic that countless Super Mario
games have employed over the years
departing far from her traditional look
Peach is also shown wearing a white and
pink jumpsuit with a pink scarf this
look is practically a direct translation
of her Mario Kart 8 Race in costume the
second Super Mario Brothers movie
trailer is worth skimming through for
costume changes and famous locations
Galore but one would be remiss to not
bring up the countless beloved
characters that make split-second cameos
throughout in Bowser's Lair alone we see
a few bum bombs shy guys Goombas Hammer
Bros and piranha plants among a large
crowd of Koopa Troopers a Bullet Bill
later pops up to give Mario a hard time
much like the aforementioned cheap Jeeps
for those hoping to see more familiar
faces than those already announced the
Super Mario Brothers movie more than has
you covered for all of you Kong family
fans out there you'll be delighted to
know that several Kongs pop up in this
teaser in addition to Donkey Kong and
Cranky Kong you can also see several
other Kongs like Diddy and funky as well
the rainbow roadshot towards the end of
the trailer are full of characters
riding along in their outlandish carts
when one thinks of the Super Mario
franchise a handful of things likely
spring to mind the characters and
Landscapes are likely up there as well
as the sounds and music that accompany
them when it comes to visual elements
wall pipes are almost certainly among
the first things to come up after all
they've been a part of Mario's video
game story from the very beginning Mario
uses them to warp around as many quests
and even access secret rooms therefore
it makes sense that that appear in the
upcoming film and we might know what
kind of purpose they serve it's heavily
implied in both Super Mario Bros movie
trailers so far that Mario and Luigi
aren't from the Mushroom Kingdom or any
of the surrounding areas there's a human
has a mustache just like you especially
in Mario's case he seems lost and pretty
overwhelmed by the situation he's in the
new teaser further fleshes out this idea
by including a few shots of Mario and
Luigi tumbling through mysterious
winding lanes that weave in and out of
clouds these past lead to Green ports
that evoke images of warp pipes could
these Vault pipes be portals to other
Wells that Mario and Luigi plunge into
we'll have to wait and see for sure
standing side by side with Princess
Peach in her defense of the Mushroom
Kingdom is Toad the short
mushroom-headed Adventurer is a video
game Legend who made his debut in 1985's
Super Mario Brothers and the decades
since he's become a fan favorite the
world over and his appearance has become
iconic for the Super Mario Brothers
movie he seems to maintain his usual
Ensemble of a blue and yellow vest with
white pants and a red and white mushroom
cap which is definitively not a hat
however he also seems to pay homage to
another less well-known toad character
as Toad and peeps go out to confront an
invading Bowser we see them eat brandish
a weapon of some kind Peach goes for a
spear with two ax blades attached to the
top or toad grabs something a bit less
intimidating a frying pan this is far
from an ideal weapon for battling
someone as formidable as Bowser but it
is a fun reference to Super Nintendo
World favorite Chef toad introduced in
2021 with the opening of Super Nintendo
World the theme park character is the
head chef at kinopio's Cafe in most of
depictions he's shown holding a frying
pan hence the connection to the Super
Mario Brothers movie version of toad but
that's not the only toad that this
version of the character is inspired by
in 2014 Nintendo released a spin-off
game for its popular Super Mario 3D
World platformer the new game Captain
Toad treasure Tracker featured a unique
version of the toad character carrying a
very heavy Explorer's backpack towed in
the Super Mario Brothers movie Don's a
familiar accessory on his back as he
heads out for adventure with Peach and
Mario a Super Mario Brothers movie opens
on April 7 2023 and will likely bring
with it even more small details that
will have Super Mario fans jumping for
joy
foreign
[Music]